♪ Best Friends Challenge ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-All right, now --
-You better not give me
a pen and a paper.
-No, but here we go.
Get ready for this.
Now the game works
like "The Newlywed Game"
but for friends.
So we're gonna take turns
reading questions about each
other from the Best Friends Box.
And we'll try to write down...
[ Laughter ]
...the same answer.
Now, we didn't plan
any of this out.
All right, here we go.
Right here.
I will read the first question.
-Wait, wait. You --
This is about me.
When you read, it's --
-Yes.
I'm going to guess about
if you're my best friend.
-Okay.
-Here we go. Ready?
-Oh, this is about me.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-If Jimmy
had a signature candle,
what would
the candle smell like?
-Oh.
-Be careful now.
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-If I had a signature candle,
what would
the candle smell like?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Um...
Mine are all inappropriate,
always.
I can't do it.
-If I had a signature candle,
what would
the candle smell like?
♪♪
I'm trying to --
trying to give hints.
[ Laughter ]
If I had a signature candle...
-Okay.
-...what would the candle --
-I don't think
I'm gonna be good at this.
-I think we got --
I think we got this one.
Chrissy,
what did you write down?
-Your daughters?
[ Laughter ]
-That's so cute,
'cause I'm always hugging them.
-You're always giving them hugs,
you say.
-Yeah, I am, I do.
I love them.
I put cotton candy.
That's all right.
Very close.
-I feel like --
-My daughters
smell like cotton candy.
We almost got --
Judges?
No, they didn't --
[ Bell dings ]
-Okay.
-No, they're being very nice.
-They were being nice.
All right.
-Everything else was --
I would get in trouble.
-Here we go.
-Okay.
-That is your card up there.
-And then, here we go.
So, we didn't get that one,
but we have more chances to win.
-Yes, we did. It dinged.
Okay, Jimmy.
-Yes.
-If we had a catch phrase,
what would it be?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Well, remember we used to,
all the time, we would go...
[ Laughter ]
S-h-h-h...
-Together we would go...
[ Laughter ]
Together, me and you,
we always had a catchphrase
when we would go...
-Yep.
♪♪
Okay.
I feel good about this.
-Yeah, me too.
I feel good about it.
Here we go.
My answer is...
Boo-yah!
Chrissy, your answer is...
-Boo-yah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-How did we get that?
-Yes!
I have no idea.
[ Both laugh ]
-Boo-yah!
[ Laughter ]
-I got excited.
-Oh, I got excited.
That was really good.
I felt the vibes with that one.
-Baby's going. Okay.
-Baby's kicking on that one.
-Baby's going.
-Boo-yah! It was awesome.
-Okay.
-Here you go.
I will read the next question.
Here we go.
Yeah, we're getting warmed up.
We are BFFs. All right.
What is Chrissy's
favorite swear word?
[ Laughter ]
Well...
This is a family show.
-Can I really write it?
-Chrissy's favorite swear word.
Oh, I don't know, man.
♪♪
-I feel...
-I know, I feel -- right?
-Yeah, I know you feel it.
-I feel like I should --
-But don't.
-No?
-Don't.
[ Laughter ]
Are you feeling it or are you --
-I feel like
I shouldn't write it.
-Don't feel.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
All right.
What did you write?
Oh, no, you're still writing.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know!
Okay. I --
Me? I show now?
-Yes.
[ Drum roll ]
All right, good, yep.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
Dude!
This is a record!
-Whew!
I've never gotten --
-Wow!
-This is fantastic!
-We can't show that, can we?
-We are --
No.
We can show half of it, maybe.
-Okay.
-But it's all good.
It's all good.
We are on the same vibe.
All right,
this is the last one.
I think already we won,
but this is great.
We have one more for you.
-Okay.
-Your turn to read,
and here we go.
But I'm very excited about this.
I think we're BFFs.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, Jimmy.
-Mm-hmm.
-If we were throwing a costume
party, what would the theme be?
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Like a...
♪♪
-[ Laughing ]
-But you -- But you can't --
No!
But you gave me a little --
[ Laughter ]
Now John's gonna kill me now.
-No.
-Here we go.
[ Drum roll ]
[ Laughter ]
Wait. All right.
Maybe --
Should I give mine first?
-Yeah.
[ Drum roll ]
Wait.
Should you?
-I don't know.
I don't know if I should now.
I want to kind of change it.
-At the same time?
-Let's go at the same time.
I said...
[ Drum roll ]
I don't know why I said this.
-I don't know why
I said this, either.
I don't even know why.
-I don't even why I said this.
-Me neither.
-All right, I said...
"Eyes Wide Shut."
-Me too!
I said "Eyes Wide Shut"!
-For real?
Are you kidding me?!
Yo!
Are you kidding me?
[ Both laugh ]
Yo!
We are best friends!
-We're best friends!
-Chrissy Teigen, everybody!
How did we do that?